there's certain things you don't like
about yourself that's judgment that's
not self-awareness so has there ever
been a time in your life where you have
felt like you had too much
self-awareness there's no such thing as
too much self-awareness there's such a
thing as too much judgment on oneself
too much self-awareness doesn't have any
negative impact if you know more about
yourself that's wonderful and everyone
here needs to judge themselves just a
little less and a little bit of fear may
be mixed in there too of course fear is
in there and everyone's got fear that's
okay it's about giving yourself some
Grace it's about taking a deep breath
and understanding we all are going to go
through trials and tribulations good and
bad don't beat yourself up love yourself
and that gives you the capacity to love
everybody else yeah